[Music]
having an effective workout program is
extremely important towards achieving
your fitness goals you can't just have a
goal and expect to achieve it if you
don't have a clear and detailed plan
without it you're probably wasting your
time and effort
here's what we need to know there isn't
a one plan fits all solution
that's because we're all different so
creating an exercise program varies
based on your age
goal fitness level lifestyle and more
even with tons of workout videos out
there you still need to have the
knowledge of knowing why you're doing
this workout rather than just blindly
following it so what i'll be sharing
with you today are the foundations to
start a simple yet effective workout
program it might sound daunting but once
you know the basics and build from there
it isn't difficult in fact it is a lot
of fun i'm going to try to keep it
really simple and break it down into
five steps
consistency is the number one factor
that will get you results you have to
train frequently across a long period of
time so let's get it right from the
beginning this is a long-term commitment
that needs discipline
there's no shortcuts in getting the
results you want hence the first step is
to assess your lifestyle and create a
personalized program that will be
consistent for you
ask yourself these questions
how many days in a week can i dedicate
to exercising
how long can each workout session be
what time of the day suits my schedule
grab a pen and paper and write it down
for instance i like to work out five
days in a week and have two rest days my
workout days will be monday tuesday
thursday friday and saturday my rest
days will be wednesday and sunday
for each session it'll be an hour long
and i like to get it done first thing in
the morning before i start my day
be specific and realistic because we
want this to be a doable plan
not something which you'll give yourself
excuses down the road
if you can dedicate one hour every day
that's great but if you're tied down to
work and family commitments and can only
spare 20 to 30 minutes a day that's
absolutely fine as well working out for
a longer period of time doesn't
necessarily equate to better or quicker
results rather it's about how consistent
and efficient your workout is in order
to achieve results
i've known of so many success stories
from people who can only spare 20 to 30
minutes a day doing the fear workouts
but because they were consistent they
saw results
another common question i get asked
often is when is the best time to
workout
the simple answer is there is no such
thing as the best time to workout
the best time is when it's most
convenient for you and fits your
schedule that way you're more likely to
stick to your routine instead of having
reasons not to train so if morning is
best for you then stick to the morning
if evening works better then keep your
workout to the evening once you have
figured out your training schedule make
a commitment to yourself and complete
the training no matter what
know that consistency is the most
important thing in creating a successful
program
[Music]
next part to figure out is what workouts
should i do there are so many workout
videos out there but you have no idea
where to start and what to do for
beginners it's important to know that
you have to perform total body workouts
focusing on all major muscles in order
to burn fat and increase lean muscle
mass
i've said this too many times but allow
me to say it once more we cannot spot
reduce fat typically there are two types
of training strength training or cardio
of course there are also workouts which
combines both such as hit interval and
circuit type training
these types of trainings are the most
efficient way to burn fat and to tone up
in a short period of time
let's look at the difference between
strength versus cardio
strength training or weight lifting are
exercises aimed at improving your
strength and to build lean muscles
strength training is important because
the more lean muscles you have the
higher your metabolic rate will be that
means your body will be burning fat more
efficiently even when you're at rest
here are some examples
cardio or aerobics are exercises that
are intense enough to increase your
breathing and heart rate at a continuous
and consistent pace
cardio exercises are important to build
stamina to burn calories and excess fat
from the body
here are some examples
which should you be focusing on that
really depends on your goal if your goal
is to lose weight then you need a
combination of both cardio and strength
training if your goal is to gain weight
then you need to incorporate a lot more
strength training into your program and
only perform cardio occasionally so
let's say my goal is to lose weight and
add more muscle tone
based on my workout days i'll split it
into 2 days of strength training 2 days
of heat conditioning workouts and 1 day
of low intensity or steady paced cardio
for example
monday can be lower body strength
training tuesday will be total body heat
and conditioning workout thursday upper
body strength training
friday total body heat and conditioning
workout and saturday can be bar yoga
pilates brisk walking swimming or hiking
go onto my channel and check out my
workout playlist for different types of
workouts
the third factor is to figure out your
workout volume how many reps and sets to
do how heavy to lift and how long to
rest in between exercises
these are mainly for strength training
i've received quite a number of
questions asking if 2 kilos is enough or
if 5 kilos is enough i can't give you a
straight answer because it comes down to
your own strength and goals
let's get to the basics of understanding
sets and reps
sets refer to repeating the same
exercise a certain number of rounds for
instance performing 10 squats in one set
and you may want to repeat it for
another two more sets with rest in
between sets for absolute beginners i
would suggest that you start with two
sets and as you progress increase to
three or four sets per exercise
repetitions or reps refers to the number
of times you perform an exercise during
a set so for instance it can be 10 reps
of squats how many reps should you
perform varies depending on your goal
and fitness level to give you a training
baseline 12 to 20 reps or more is
primarily to build muscular endurance
and size endurance means to train your
muscles to perform a certain move for an
extended period of time
doing high reps means you'll be lifting
lighter loads and because we want to
improve endurance that means shorter
rest between sets 30 to 60 seconds
6 to 12 reps is hypertrophy training
hypertrophy is an increase in growth of
muscle cells achieved through weight
lifting
this training is for all of you who want
to tone up and improve muscle definition
because you're lifting heavier with
lower reps the rest time between sets
will be about 60 to 90 seconds
less than six reps is to build super
dense muscle strength and power because
the wraps are lower that means you're
going to be lifting a lot heavier
weights focusing all your effort into
those few reps you'll also need longer
to recover and the rest time between
sets is about 3 to 5 minutes long hence
depending on your training goal you will
need to adjust the weight accordingly
for example if you're training for
hypertrophy and you can perform up to 20
reps then the weights are too light you
have to increase the load
you also have to adjust the weight
according to the body parts you're
training your leg muscles are a lot
bigger hence you can lift a lot heavier
compared to your shoulder muscles you
can't just stick to one weight and
perform the entire body and remember
proper form is extremely important in
order for you to engage the right
muscles and to avoid injuries every rep
should be a quality rep
now that you have a solid workout
program and you're consistent with it
the next important factor is progression
to keep improving and seeing results
your workouts need to get harder over
time you can't just stick to a beginner
workout which you've been doing for the
past two months and wonder why am i not
seeing results if you fail to progress
in your training that's when you'll hit
a plateau saying that however do not
make things harder too quickly i do
understand that some of us can get
really impatient and want to lift
heavier within the next few sessions it
takes time to build strength and
endurance
progress slowly and gradually this way
you will still create change but without
the risk of injuries which may cause you
to miss even more training days as a
rule of thumb you want to train for four
to six weeks at any given level of
difficulty before adding more challenge
to your training training progression
can be increasing the work load that
means lifting heavier weights or
increasing your running speed
increasing workout volume whether it's
more reps sets or intervals increasing
the workout time
reducing rest time or introducing
tougher moves there's no one straight
answer to how you can progress in your
workout but the longer you train and
understand your body you will start to
make adjustments to your training in
order to challenge yourself and to also
keep things fun fresh and not so
monotonous that way you will look
forward to your training sessions
we often take this for granted but
keeping track of your workout sessions
are extremely important
it's the only way where you can look
back review each session track your
progress and even celebrate your
successes along the way have a fitness
journal and keep track of every single
workout
your record should be both objective and
subjective
record the exercises weights
sets
reps workout duration and rest time
record how your body feels
recovery level and mental state having
these records will allow you to see what
works what's not working so that over
time you can create a training program
that's effective and efficient for you
it really does take time to figure out
your own body you can't just create a
training program and know that this will
work immediately
you need to consistently adapt and make
changes along the way besides that
having a record is also a great way to
keep you accountable to your goals for
instance you'll know if you manage to
fit in five days of workout as planned
this information is key to show you
results and to keep you going now that
you know the foundation of building a
solid workout program i want you to put
this into action and try it out for
yourself to get you through your fitness
journey i've also designed a
well-structured training program every
month on my fitness app called feel all
the workouts are effective easy to
follow with clear instructions and
they're led by internationally certified
trainers so you know you're in safe
hands plus the workouts can be done at
home with very minimal equipment
do check it out and sign up for free on
fieldlife.com or download on the app
store or google play
with all the knowledge and information
let's also not forget that nutrition and
diet is still 80 percent of the results
to see permanent changes it is a
combination of having an effective
training program eating a well-balanced
diet that fits in with your goal and
getting enough rest daily if you enjoyed
this video if you find this video to be
useful then do like this video and share
it on with your friends do also hit the
subscribe button check out a lot more
workout videos nutritional tips and
recipes on my youtube channel and i will
see you in my next video stay safe and
all the best